listen man you know I'm a big fan of
your work I had a ton of questions
um for people that actually don't know
your work if someone has never seen
anything what is the first thing you
want them watching and why Stephen great
question out of the gates
um
you know I'd have to answer that from
not from like an audience perspective
but more of a personal perspective is
and it's more based on like
what more I was going through in my life
or the times that I had on that shoot
are more so it may not necessarily be
the shoot itself or the film itself
but and this will probably come
satellite in a couple times is Godless
um
I just loved being in New Mexico and on
that shoot and on a horse
I loved the character I loved the story
but I just loved like you know it's one
of the greatest moments in my life as an
actor was having a walkie-talkie in my
saddle bag and them saying go head over
the hill and then we'll tell you when to
come back
and I went over that hill and I sat out
there and waited for them to call but
you know obviously something happened
with production and they were messing
with something out so saw this time went
by and I was sitting there on that horse
and that cowboy hat and all that stuff
and it just fell
like such a euphoric moment of like holy
[ __ ] like this is what it was like 150
years ago right here looking out over
nothing you can't see any but nothing
and you're on this horse
that it was just sort of a moment of
bliss that stuck with me forever and I
had one of the greatest times on that
job but it's like those little moments
like that are are more so what makes me
remember it and not necessarily the the
role in which one would know me from if
that makes sense yeah um if I remember
correctly that was a seven episode
series and it was fantastic oh thank you
so much we I I I had so much fun
shooting that job I wish it could have
lasted 20 years yeah that was one of
those things where I was wondering if
they could do more with it but anyway
um when did you actually feel like you
could pay your rent and be an actor for
a living
you never feel like you can pay your
rent as an actor for a living
in the future
you know you you you you kind of feel
like you can based on what's
happening but I I
was
22 working as a carpenter
um oh you're doing the Harrison Ford
thing I I mean I guess I think Harrison
was probably a much more precise and
better Carpenter than myself but but
yeah I was building uh sets for this
event planning company down in south of
Los Angeles
and I got a commercial
and so
I I and then I got another one and then
after that it was it was like I I made
more money on those two commercials than
my entire salary for the year which I
know which was like I don't know 35
Grand or something
and I remember I went through a long you
know two three years of getting tons of
commercials and I quit my job and I
never had another job well you know 26
years old it was a lull you know and I
went right back to like remodeling I was
doing remodeling uh closets you know as
a carpenter so even when you feel like
things are
never going to change you know they have
so many times throughout my career that
you just take don't take anything for
granted and it just makes you so much
more grateful for any work that you have
and so that's more I feel like where am
I
head is is that I'm just grateful and
try not to think about the future or the
past just think about now and like now
is great now is good now I can pay my
rent
um I don't know if I will be in six
months but I'll cross that bridge then
uh many people don't many people see you
as a more dramatic actor
um when uh when I believe will and Josh
called you and said we want you to do
this which is more comedic
um were you like yes oh my God yes
well no the first thing I said to them
was like well y'all are shooting a
comedy and they said yeah I said well
why are y'all calling me you know and
they said I had worked with them 15
years ago doing commercials and so I'd
done a bunch of you know sort of comic
comedy commercials for them
and they're and I just said I was
they're like what do you mean I was like
no one in Hollywood thinks I'm funny you
know and they're like well we know
you're funny I was like well good luck
convincing the studio of that you know
and anyways they they they fought for me
they really did I had done some some
comedic stuff for them in the past and
they I think they sort of saw an ability
that I had that that hadn't been
utilized or isn't being utilized and and
I'm so grateful for them to even give me
that that opportunity so I was over the
moon I've been trying to to get into
something lighter than drama for for
over five years and so I feel like I'm
just now sort of scratching the surface
on on opening up
you know the different genres that I've
been able to work in one of the things
uh about making a film like this is you
can actually share it with your entire
family you know kids uh and we is that
one of the things you were like oh my
God everyone in my family can watch this
100 because everything I've done in
in the last like 10 years no one in my
family can watch so so so like my kids
see me go and come and go so like I was
so elated to be able to have a project
that I could show my kids and and say
like look this I even brought him to sat
in Atlanta and showed him the the the
sad and the the crocodile and and the CG
I mean all the different suits and stuff
and so it was just awesome and for them
to see that and then be able to also as
well take them to the premiere of it
um you know yeah I was it's a it's a
really sort of special moment for a
father you know what I mean or I imagine
for any parent to to
you know show your children what it is
that you do instead of telling them
about what it is that you do and I don't
tell them much other than I'm an actor
and that's you know they're starting to
come to an age now where that making a
lot more sense to them be honest is the
Nintendo switch behind you yours or the
kids
you want me to be real honest
it's my kids and they only got one game
on it because I don't know how to set it
up or work it or anything and so like it
really just sits there and until like I
take the time to sit down and figure out
how to like work it and download the
games and stuff it's just
it just sits there
uh I I have a Nintendo switch and I
there was a game I played Animal
Crossing for a little while and uh
anyway it was a it was I haven't I
haven't been a gamer since
uh Madden John Madden and probably 99
2000 which is probably my last year you
were playing on the original PlayStation
not the original PlayStation no it was
uh I I don't remember I think college
was around the time that I was like all
right
I gotta give this up you know I gotta
focus on other things
um one of the things listen Javier
Bardem is such a talented actor and will
and Josh told me about how he really
went for it and was you know performing
and all just uh so can you talk a little
bit about you know getting to see him up
close and the way he works because he
really always gives it 100 percent
I mean I you know not only is 100
talented the guy's 100 professional too
um
the
sort of energy that he brings the
composure that he brings as an actor in
as a person just that is incredibly
contagious he was really really willing
to like try anything and do anything and
really put himself out there wouldn't
you know is what most actors do but like
this was sort of a stretch I felt like a
little bit for him and for him to really
come out and and deliver on that level
and and also you know just be such a
wonderful human being in the whole
process of it
um
I mean he's a that to me is what a real
movie star is you know to take all that
stress and all that stuff and and just
you know Focus forward and stay
professional and stuff but he was so uh
endearing complimentary
nice fun free
um and on top of that I'm a fan of the
guy for so long so for me it was a real
moment to to that I was you know it was
a bonus I got to do this comedy will and
Josh and also you know I got to work
with an actor I've been wanting to work
with since I started this so um
the whole thing was sort of an
eye-opening experience
um you've done a lot of different
projects uh which shot or sequence in
all the things you've done uh do you
think ended up being like the most
challenging one to pull off
it would be a commercial
uh that I did for Mountain Dew
uh with a a company called tractor this
Swedish uh directorial uh production
company here and they were crazy I'd
done a ton of crazy crazy commercials
for this one them and on this one they
were like hey we want you to swim with
sharks and I was like
any other production company I just said
yeah but it was tractor and I was like
all right I know you guys I'm not
actually going to swim with the shark
and they're like no we'll we'll figure
it out of course I was skeptical anyways
they had me hanging from these wires
and we had to match frame this this
dorsal fin of a shark that was a green
screen
while shooting water cannons at me and
swinging at a certain time to match
frame to make it look like I was riding
this mechanical shark or this this great
white shark
and I just remember it was in December
down in Baja at Fox Baja and it was
freezing cold uh these cans were getting
shot we were in the water for four days
you know it was just it was a lot of fun
but it was it was definitely one of my
most memorable shoots of me saying to
myself
you know I really got to get out of
these commercials and get into something
else only to know that like you know now
I'm doing the same thing but it's
sitting five months in the snow or in
the water you know
um but that's a definitely a memorable
uh
shoot for me was that Mountain Dew spot
that I did you know I don't know 16
years ago my I have a lot of uh actor
friends and the thing that people don't
realize is if you the thing about a
commercial though is if you book a big
National ad that ends up going for a
while it can buy you a house
yeah I think probably 15 years ago that
could happen but the the commercial
industry is I mean yes there are those
those yes they are they're far and few
between them these days from what I hear
but but yeah we we we worked a lot on
commercials and I went on you know six
or seven auditions a week
and so it only got about 15 to 18 of
them a year so if you look at the odds
it's not that high but but we everybody
at this company we were at jpa we
everybody was there did all right you
know every time I talk to you I bring up
a certain show it's called Halt and
Catch Fire uh because I [ __ ] love it
um do you find that I mean I do um do
you find that people continue to want to
talk to you about it or that it's have
more people seen it I'm just because
it's so good you know what I mean and
when it was on it was five people
watching it and I was one of the five
I knew you were one of the five we
talked about this because I knew the
other four
um
honestly it's it's I I thought the show
was good when we were making it
um I thought it was the the writers had
really and the showrunners had really
done an interesting job I didn't think
it was before ahead of its time you know
you just don't know why things aren't
catching on but I always believed in the
show and and believed in the in the
writers and the show Runners and and uh
it was just getting eyes on it I feel
like and during the pandemic when
everybody went through those their
you know list of things to watch they
eventually hit it and and I feel like a
lot of people watch that show over the
pandemic and I did get a lot of uh you
know whatever texts and stuff saying hey
I hadn't seen the show it's really good
and and and uh I just feel like you know
that that was Dennis wanders you know in
regards to that show the sad thing about
it is that I really wanted the show to
keep going and get into modern times
with computers and so you know it didn't
really gain speed until we had already
been shut down so
um
you know I would have it was a great
show a wonderful experience great cast a
great time huge learning experience for
me it was my first series I'd ever done
um so that was a big
um uh I'm very grateful for that
learning experience but
but um yeah people people seem to to to
to
we're viewing it much more over the
pandemic and after the pandemic it did
feel like that it did get the viewership
that we never got
um previously when we were airing yeah I
mean listen I'm just grateful it was
even on you know and it had more than
one season and you know it's just it's
Amer you know what I mean every season
we did we had to bookend it because we
just never knew if we were coming back
and uh you know that's the nature of the
game but but it would have been so nice
to to know that and tie in because these
guys would have tied in things from
different seasons and stuff but
regardless they did a fantastic job at
weaving that uh that needle through that
show I totally agree I looked at the
always accurate IMDb and you have some
pretty cool stuff coming up you got to
work on Fairyland and night [ __ ] and uh
you know blood for dust the line um do
you take breaks
yeah I mean I I do I I I I I took a huge
break at the beginning of the year and I
took about four months off and hung with
my kids and my partner and
you know I do take times off but like
also when I start working I'll kind of I
I in a perfect world and you kind of
bang out as much stuff as you can all
together and then pull the rip cord and
you know take two months off three
months off or so but I love working so
it's it's the hardest thing in this
business people would ask me what's the
hardest thing in entertainment business
it's saying no
you know it's like you you want to do
all these projects and you waited around
for a decade to work and you couldn't
get it and now it's here and you have to
say no to things is really uh confusing
and and hard sometimes I can't imagine
um but tell me actually of the projects
you got to work with Amy Adams
um and I'm curious about this these
upcoming projects what can you say about
some of them
um uh Amy the film I do in my pitch with
Amy Adams um Mari Heller was heading up
as director and just with those two I
mean an incredible Duo
um
it's a wild wild movie and story and
weird and it's totally out of the brain
I mean it's a an adaptation but I mean
the film is out of the brain of Mari
Heller so it's we did some crazy stuff
on it
um I think it's going to be really sad
and fun funny endearing uh there's a bit
of a horror element to it
um but all in all this one is going to
be such a surprise I think to me and
even a bigger surprise to audiences that
for me to even sort of try to explain
what it's about or what happens in it
would not do it justice and uh also I
probably could be way off I heard a
little bit about what it's about and it
sounds crazy yeah it's it's and also
when they put it together with all the
things that are happening to Amy and and
stuff that I it's it's going to be
interesting and then
um Fairyland is a film that Andrew
Durham directed
um with uh Greg loturo and and Sophia
Coppola uh producing and
It's A Memoir of Steve Abbott a bisexual
or gay
writer poet that
raised his daughter as a single father
in the Castro
just before the AIDS epidemic
and essentially it's the story about the
love of a father's for his daughter and
you know it's a true story but also for
me it was about what a father the
extents that a father will go to for
their child you know and how you just it
doesn't matter if you get it right or
get it wrong as long as you show up as a
parent
um
I think it's going to be a beautiful
film
um
I'm really excited about it and um blood
for dust I'm I'm just about to to get
started on that um Rod blackhurst is
heading that up as a film as the
Director
um it starts Josh Lucas and Kit
Harington as well
um and it's more of a fun
uh popcorn uh
uh cat and mouse cat and mouse a story
but but like with Rod blackhurst's touch
to it you know he he's very very
specific um you know I I don't want to
use another film to sort of explain it
but um
you know I hadn't started it either I
think you discover a lot about a film
and a character when you're doing it so
I'll probably have more for you the next
time I talk to you about that particular
project I I I won't uh I totally
understand
um uh I I'm basically out of time with
you I'm just gonna say that um as always
it is a pleasure to talk I wish you
nothing but the best you know and uh
obviously if we can ever do anything for
you on Collide or just let me know
you're awesome Steven and again thank
you for for all your shout outs and
being a fan and all that stuff it's it's
so appreciated and I love that you were
with us on Hall and Catch Fire from the
get-go it means a lot to me man [ __ ]
I love that show you know and I also
love AMC for putting it on I know right
they stuck with us they stuck with us
when no one was watching they still give
us a chance and I I am hugely grateful
to them as well
um on that note good luck with the rest
of your speed dating today and
um you know the switch is easy to hook
up figure it out I think your kids will
like it you're awesome Steven
later man later buddy